Ласкаво просимо назад до «Квантових обчислень на практиці». Я твоя ведуча Олівія Лейнс. Минулого разу ми розглянули приклад
квантового підходу до задачі оптимізації, відомої як Max-Cut, використовуючи формулювання QUBO. Ми
заглибились досить детально, але це був лише один приклад одного підходу. Сьогодні ми обговоримо короткострокові застосування
ширше та розвинемо інтуїцію щодо різних типів задач, для яких ми очікуємо знайти корисні квантові рішення,
і розглянемо деякі нещодавні приклади важливих робіт, виконаних у нашій спільноті на рівні утиліти.
Раніше ми коротко обговорили, що не всі задачі потребують додаткової обчислювальної потужності,
зокрема квантових обчислень, щоб бути розв'язаними ефективно. Це задачі, які тобі вже найбільш
знайомі: арифметика, гортання соціальних мереж, гра в Tetris, Doom чи інші відеоігри. Загалом ми вважаємо
їх легкими задачами. З іншого боку, є дуже складні задачі, наприклад пошук простих множників величезних
цілих чисел — це основа шифрування RSA і те, для чого насправді був розроблений алгоритм Шора. Ще один
приклад — пошук рішення у невідсортованому наборі даних. Теоретично це можна розв'язати за допомогою квантового алгоритму, відомого
як алгоритм Гровера. Однак більшість експертів погоджуються, що такі типи алгоритмів потребуватимуть
впровадження виправлення помилок, а технологічно ми ще не там. Тому, просуваючись далі в цьому
уроці та у своїй освітній подорожі в квантових обчисленнях, пам'ятай: ми шукаємо це «солодке місце» десь посередині.
Це складна задача, але саме це робить її такою цікавою. Одна річ, яку ми ще недостатньо обговорили, —
це теорія обчислювальної складності. Одна з причин полягає в тому, що вона може бути дещо лякаючою, і так,
складною. Теорія обчислювальної складності — це розділ комп'ютерних наук, який класифікує обчислювальні задачі
за ступенем їхньої складності. Існує безліч різних класів складності в класичних обчисленнях, але найбільш
фундаментальними є задачі класу P — задачі, які можна розв'язати за поліноміальний час, що масштабується зі
збільшенням задачі, тобто вони є легкими для розв'язання. Наступний, складніший тип — задачі NP,
що означає «недетерміновано поліноміальні». Це задачі, відповіді на які можна перевірити за поліноміальний час, але не
обов'язково розв'язати. Далі йде NP-повна складність, і тут ми переходимо до справді складних задач без відомого
поліноміального розв'язку. Саме тут живуть відомі задачі, як-от задача комівояжера і навіть гра
Судоку. Коли квантові обчислення виникли, принаймні теоретично, люди доклали чимало зусиль, намагаючись
з'ясувати, який клас задач ці нові типи комп'ютерів зможуть розв'язувати ефективно. Був винайдений новий клас
задач — задачі з обмеженою квантовою помилкою за поліноміальний час, або BQP скорочено. Їхнє точне визначення
дещо довге, але це клас задач вирішення, що розв'язуються квантовим комп'ютером за поліноміальний час із невеликою
ймовірністю помилки. Ймовірність помилки існує, бо квантове вимірювання є принципово випадковим, але
ймовірність помилки може бути довільно малою. Всі ці класи живуть у більшому класі, який ми називаємо PSPACE, і саме там,
як ми думаємо, живе BQP відносно всіх інших типів задач, але математично довести це дуже складно.
Ти помітиш, що квантові задачі BQP не обов'язково перетинаються з NP-повними задачами.
Однак ти, можливо, все ж бачив деякі підходи до квантових обчислень, спрямовані на розв'язання NP-повних задач. Чому б
це було так? Одне поширене хибне уявлення полягає в тому, що немає сенсу досліджувати рішення
для задач на кшталт задачі комівояжера та інших NP-повних задач для квантового комп'ютера, або будь-якої задачі, для якої
математичний доказ квантового прискорення не був знайдений. Але це не обов'язково має бути так.
Знайти математичний доказ того, що квантовий алгоритм швидший за класичний аналог, трапляється рідко. Шор і
Гровер — два з небагатьох прикладів, де це було зроблено досі, але це нормально. Насправді
вчені досі не змогли довіть, що класи P і NP є різними, навіть попри те, що вся інтуїція
говорить нам, що вони мусять бути різними. Також порівняння двох алгоритмів і того, як вони масштабуються, часто розглядає найгірший
сценарій для кожного. Цілком можливо, що на практиці найгірший сценарій — це не те, що ми знаходимо в реальному житті. Тому
не відчаюємось і натомість вводимо ідею евристичних рішень. Якщо ти
експериментатор, то вже знаєш і любиш такі типи рішень. Евристика — це будь-який підхід до розв'язання
задачі, що є прагматичним, але не обов'язково оптимальним, і це чудово, бо рішення не обов'язково мають
бути оптимальними, щоб бути дуже корисними. Наприклад, уяви фінансове застосування. Ми ще не знайшли
експоненційного прискорення для більшості фінансових алгоритмів, де можна було б застосувати квант, але це не обов'язково має значення — нам не потрібне оптимальне рішення
у фінансах, принаймні тому, що рішення, яке є навіть на 1% ефективнішим, може дорівнювати мільярдам доларів
прибутку. Отже, як нам дізнатися, які варіанти використання та задачі можуть підходити для квантових обчислень прямо зараз? Маю на увазі,
що є вагома причина вважати, що квантову утиліту чи навіть перевагу можна знайти або зараз,
або в найближчому майбутньому. Можливо, простіше спочатку назвати те, чого задача точно не повинна мати.
Вона не може потребувати величезної кількості qubit. У нас ще немає процесорів із тисячами до мільйонів qubit. Це одна з головних причин,
чому алгоритм Шора і подібні так далеко. Circuit також не можуть бути неймовірно глибокими. Мені справді важко
точно сказати, яка глибина circuit не буде працювати, бо це залежить від дуже багатьох факторів, але загалом, якщо твій
експеримент вимагає глибини, якої ти ще не бачив у літературі, у тебе може бути важкий час. І
нарешті, будь-який тип алгоритму, який, як ми знаємо, потребуватиме виправлення помилок, ще не може бути виконаний. Натомість нам слід шукати експерименти, які
використовують більшість доступних qubit на будь-якому QPU. Ми також наголошували на
важливості пом'якшення та придушення помилок, і нарешті, має бути очевидне розширення на майбутні
застосування, які були б важливими для суспільства і які, як ми могли б побачити, зрештою ведуть до квантової
переваги. Тепер поговоримо про деякі приклади варіантів використання, що належать до трьох основних категорій, які ми
визначили як найімовірніші для отримання сприятливих результатів у короткостроковій та середньостроковій
перспективі. Перша область — це симуляція природи. Ми вже говорили про це раніше:
існує так багато можливостей для квантових комп'ютерів покращити дослідження на молекулярному та атомному рівні.
WEBVTT
І причина в тому, що сучасні класичні методи обмежені фундаментально неефективними математичними
описами атомних структур. Зберігання та маніпулювання квантовим станом потребує експоненційного обсягу ресурсів
на класичному комп'ютері, але може ефективно виконуватися на квантовому комп'ютері — саме це робить симуляцію матеріалів
та хімічне моделювання одними з найперспективніших сфер застосування. Більш конкретно, це може призвести до
розробок у галузі секвестрації вуглекислого газу, альтернативних батарей або винаходу нових ліків. Деякі
алгоритми, що особливо актуальні в цій сфері, — це варіаційний квантовий алгоритм пошуку власних значень (VQE), який використовується для
оцінки певних властивостей матеріалу, таких як рівноважні або мінімальні енергетичні стани. Ще один приклад —
симуляція часової динаміки (TDS), цей алгоритм використовується для оцінки функцій відгуку або спектральних властивостей
матеріалів. Також хочу згадати новинку — квантову діагоналізацію на основі вибірки (SBQ), про яку, як ми думаємо,
ми будемо чути значно більше в найближчому майбутньому. Наступна сфера застосування — оптимізація. Оптимізація досить
поширена в обчисленнях, як ти можеш уявити, тому варіанти використання досить численні й різноманітні.
Однак деякі приклади, про які ми часто чуємо, — це оптимізація портфеля у фінансах, промисловий дизайн, а також
дистрибуція та ланцюги постачання. Найпоширеніший алгоритм, який ти, мабуть, почуєш у зв'язку з оптимізацією, — це той, який ми
вже розглянули досить детально: квантовий алгоритм наближеної оптимізації, або
QAOA. І нарешті, одна сфера, де спостерігалося велике збудження протягом останніх кількох років, — це квантове машинне навчання. Я
думаю, справедливо сказати, що, схоже, QML не відбудеться так скоро, як симуляція, в усій ймовірності, але проте існують
деякі вражаючі алгоритми, над якими люди постійно працюють, що відповідають деяким дуже важливим варіантам
використання. Деякі з цих можливих варіантів — обробка природної мови, аналіз мережевого трафіку і навіть виявлення
шахрайства у фінансових транзакціях. Відповідні алгоритми в цій галузі — квантова машина опорних
векторів, квантові нейронні мережі та квантові генеративні змагальні мережі. Тепер для уточнення ці три
групи, які ми щойно описали, — це широкі сфери застосування. Також варто зазначити, що в спільноті існує
користь і від груп, які працюють разом і зосереджені на конкретній темі. IBM очолила ініціативу не так давно,
яку назвали «Робочими групами», щоб допомогти колаборантам зустрітися та створити продуктивну синергію у чотирьох конкретних
сферах: охорона здоров'я та науки про життя, матеріали та HPC, фізика високих енергій і
оптимізація. Ось наші поточні групи та суб'єкти, залучені до цих зусиль. Якщо хочеш дізнатися більше про
те, чим займаються робочі групи, ми додали чотири їхніх білих книги в описі нижче. Як я вже сказала,
думаю, найкраще на цьому етапі курсу — витратити час на вивчення того, над якими задачами люди працюють на передньому
краї цієї технології, та розвинути інтуїцію для розуміння того, які типи алгоритмів будуть працювати і як
їх застосовувати. І перш ніж ми почнемо, просто хочу чітко зазначити, що головна мета тут — не зрозуміти кожну
деталь експериментів. Такий тип аналізу може бути дуже залякуючим навіть для експертів, якщо стаття трохи
виходить за межі їхньої сфери знань. Мета просто полягає в тому, щоб допомогти розвинути інтуїцію щодо типів задач, для яких квантові
комп'ютери підходять, і як з ними впоратися. І якщо тебе цікавлять дрібніші деталі й це спонукало деякі
власні ідеї, я обов'язково раджу тобі піти та прочитати самі повні статті. Конкретні варіанти використання та
статті, які ми детально розглянемо, такі: спочатку ми вивчимо статтю, яка обговорює
симуляцію динаміки адронів. Це належить до категорії фізики високих енергій. Далі ми розглянемо задачу
оптимізації, зокрема квантову оптимізацію зі зміщеним полем і контрадіабатичним керуванням. І нарешті ми розглянемо ще одну
задачу симуляції, але цього разу зосереджену на мРНК — ключовій молекулі для
розробки ліків та терапевтичних засобів. Незалежно від того, знайомий ти з цими статтями чи ні, — це не проблема. Ми розглянемо
всі три. Це важливі статті, що вирішують задачі значного масштабу та показують, як квантові
комп'ютери починають використовуватися як ще один метод наукового дослідження. Перша — симуляція динаміки адронів.
Ми зануримося в статтю групи Мартіна Севіджа з Університету Вашингтона під назвою «Квантові
симуляції динаміки адронів у моделі Швінгера з використанням 112
qubit». Якщо ти не фізик високих енергій, ти все ж можеш бути знайомий із терміном «адрон», наприклад у контексті
Великого адронного колайдера, або LHC — гігантського прискорювача частинок довжиною 27 кілометрів, який уможливив
нарешті спостереження бозона Хіггса. Адрон — це субатомна складена частинка, що складається з інших малих
частинок, які називаються кварками. Деякими прикладами є нейтрони та протони. Для деякого контексту: LHC був побудований
для вивчення фундаментальної фізики та того, що відбувається з частинками, коли вони стикаються при надвисоких енергіях
у цій круговій трубі. Роблячи це, вчені сподіваються дізнатися більше про те, як виникла рання Всесвіт,
і, як я вже сказала, він також використовувався для пошуку бозона — невловимої частинки, відповідальної за масу
фундаментальних частинок. Тепер, у принципі, взаємодії цих частинок можна
симулювати від початку до кінця за допомогою достатньо потужного квантового комп'ютера. Ми ще не там, але
прогрес досягається. Модель Швінгера — це проста модель для симуляції деякої з цієї динаміки, яка стала однією з
найпопулярніших моделей на вибір. Деталі моделі не надто важливі прямо зараз, але для тих, хто
цікавиться: це модель, що описує поведінку електронів і позитронів, які взаємодіють через фотони в 1+1 D
вимірах — тобто один просторовий вимір і час. Модель має багато спільного з квантовою
хромодинамікою, яка описує взаємодію кварків і адронів. Це вкрай складно симулювати, тому
модель Швінгера часто використовується як іграшкова модель для дослідження деяких явищ, спільних для
обох. Тепер спосіб, яким ми будемо продовжувати цей приклад та інші вибрані приклади, полягає
у постановці ряду запитань. Перше: чому ми мали підстави вважати, що симуляція цього
на квантовому комп'ютері взагалі спрацює? У цьому випадку електрони та позитрони в моделі Швінгера мають ефект екранування,
що спричиняє експоненційне затухання кореляцій між далекими феміонами з відстанню. Це означає, що
немає стільки далекосяжних взаємодій між qubit на одному боці чіпа та іншим на протилежному боці чіпа
що, як ми знаємо, дуже схильне до помилок — тож це дійсно добре для апаратного забезпечення, яке ми маємо сьогодні. Далі:
чи взагалі цікава ця тема? Гадаю, я вже певною мірою переконав тебе, що так — фізика високих енергій має велике
значення: люди були готові витратити мільярди доларів на будівництво LHC, і тисячі науковців та
технічних фахівців по всьому світу присвятили своє життя цій галузі — настільки вона важлива. Але
модель Швінгера спрощена і не призначена для опису трьох просторових вимірів. Проте вона є
важливою моделлю, оскільки й досі надає актуальні тестовані зрізи та корисне спрощення повної
теорії. Насамкінець — як виконувалась ця робота, або який підхід вони б використали, якби хотіли продовжити роботу в
симуляційних експериментах? VQE є одним із найпоширеніших підходів, і перший крок майже завжди однаковий:
підготовка основного стану — в цьому випадку це вакуумний стан. У цьому експерименті вони використали нову версію VQE під назвою SC
adapt VQE для підготовки як основного стану, так і хвильового пакета адрона поверх вакууму. Наступний крок —
дозволити адронам еволюціонувати або поширюватися в часі. Зрештою, нам потрібно визначити
спостережувані величини, які ми хочемо виявити. Якщо ці кроки здались тобі дещо знайомими — за винятком частини про хвильовий пакет адрона —
то тому, що вони дуже схожі на те, що ми розглядали на прикладі QAOA в попередньому епізоді.
Сподіваюся, ти вже починаєш помічати певні закономірності: компоненти, необхідні для VQE, дуже схожі на QAOA.
Ми починаємо зі знайомого стану — вакуумного стану — і потім даємо йому еволюціонувати в часі за допомогою серії показникових
гамільтоніанів, розбитих на зручні частини, де n — кількість розподілів. Єдина суттєва відмінність тут
полягає в тому, що ми створюємо хвильовий пакет адрона, зосереджений у нашому circuit, перш ніж починаємо давати йому еволюціонувати. Тож як це
робиться? Вакуумний стан є основним станом, і ми вже певною мірою розглянули, як це відображати. Тепер підготовка хвильового пакета адрона
дещо інша: у цьому вакуумі адрон можна збудити, створивши пару ферміон — антиферміон на
сусідніх вузлах. Готуючи суперпозицію таких адронів у різних місцях, можна отримати довільний хвильовий
пакет. Автори розмістили свій хвильовий пакет у центрі circuit, щоб спостерігати за еволюцією
без виходу за межі. Але пам'ятай: головна умова при роботі з шумними QPU — тримати
глибину circuit на керованому рівні. Для цього протокол SC adapt VQE використовує симетрію та
ієрархії масштабів довжини для визначення quantum circuits малої глибини для підготовки стану. Ідея полягає в тому, що це
створить ansatz з меншою кількістю параметрів, що відповідає меншій глибині. Детальніше можна
ознайомитись у статті — ми не маємо часу розглянути все тут. Тож обов'язково перевір її. А зараз погляньмо на результати. Цей експеримент було виконано на
пристрої IBM Quantum Heron, де використовувалось кілька різних типів пом'якшення та пригнічення помилок,
включно з більш сучасною технікою під назвою operator decoherence renormalization, а також dynamical decoupling, zero noise
extrapolation та Pauli twirling. Тепер спробуємо інтерпретувати дані. Спостережувана величина, яку ми фактично будемо
вимірювати, щоб спостерігати за поширенням хвильового пакета, називається хіральним конденсатом, що є дещо
абстрактним, але по суті це надплинна фаза адронів. Тепер ми можемо бачити хвильовий пакет, зосереджений тут на
вузлах, що призначені для проведення цього експерименту, де колір відповідає хіральному конденсату.
Ліва сторона показує результати без помилок із симулятора, тоді як права сторона показує результати з IBM quantum
комп'ютера Torino. В ідеалі вони мали б бути дзеркальними відображеннями одне одного завдяки симетрії, тож можна бачити, що є певні
недосконалості. Тепер ця вертикальна вісь Y відповідає відрізкам часу, які я
вимірював раніше. Тож чому б нам не зробити горизонтальні зрізи через перший і останній часові кроки даних, щоб побачити,
що відбувається з хвильовим пакетом при τ = 1 — тут, помаранчевим кольором, що відповідає
цьому зрізу — можна бачити, що хіральний конденсат вузький і локалізований, і він також дуже добре збігається з
симуляцією, зробленою для порівняння. При τ = 14, однак, він значно більш розмитий і менш
локалізований. Можливо, порівняння із симулятором тепер не таке ідеальне, але можна все одно очевидно бачити дуже гарне узгодження між теорією та даними,
що обнадіює. На завершення: це дуже класний приклад типу симуляційної роботи, про яку спочатку, можливо, не думаєш
застосовувати квантові комп'ютери. Однак насправді можна, і це працює. Не ідеально, але тобі не потрібно бути
експертом з фізики частинок, щоб побачити, що квантовий комп'ютер точно передбачає зовнішнє поширення хвильового пакета,
що саме і очікувалося. Сподіваюся, майбутні роботи в цій галузі продовжаться, і фізики високих енергій
продовжуватимуть знаходити способи включати Quantum Computing у свої робочі процеси. Мета — вирішувати теоретичні задачі точніше та
ті, що не можна вирішити класично, а також використовувати експерименти для прийняття або відхилення теорій у надії відкрити нову
фізику, побудувати вдосконалені детектори та досягти кращого розуміння природи на її найфундаментальнішому
рівні. Наш наступний приклад стосується оптимізації та буде глибоким зануренням у статтю під назвою "biased field
digitized counter adiabatic Quantum optimization", виконану членами команди Kipu Quantum та
Університету Країни Басків в Іспанії. Ми почнемо, як і раніше,
з низки визначень. Перше — counter adiabatic, що є типом еволюції, яка пригнічує неадіабатичні
ефекти, що виникають у системі незалежно від того, наскільки швидко відбуваються ці процеси. Пригадай адіабатичну теорему з
попереднього епізоду: зазвичай потрібно давати системі еволюціонувати дуже повільно, якщо хочеш, щоб вона залишалась в основному стані.
Це велика проблема, тому що чим повільніше ми маємо давати речам еволюціонувати, тим більше часу ми маємо для виникнення помилок.
Counter adiabatic driving, часто скорочується як CD, прагне подолати це шляхом
додавання членів, що протидіють цим небажаним збудженням. Головна ідея тут — прискорити весь експеримент та
зменшити глибину Quantum circuit шляхом пригнічення збуджень, що могли б призвести до паразитних
переходів. Тепер поговоримо про те, що таке bias field. Інші ітераційні алгоритми, як-от VQE, приймають класичні параметри в
ці стани та використовують класичні оптимізатори для пошуку в багатовимірному просторі параметрів того набору,
що дає мінімальне значення очікуваного значення для фіксованого гамільтоніана. В цьому випадку натомість гамільтоніан змінюється кожного
разу, адіабатично рухаючись від відомого випадку до цікавого. Але оскільки немає класичних параметрів,
що передаються, і немає варіаційної хвильової функції — як оновлюєш стан від одного проходу гамільтоніана до наступного? Що ж,
вони додають bias field до гамільтоніана: яким би не був стан із найнижчою енергією з попереднього запуску, вони додають член у
гамільтоніан, щоб зробити цей стан пріоритетним. Тож чому цей експеримент
цікавий? По-перше, це новий підхід, який можна застосовувати більш широко до інших задач оптимізації.
Але в цьому випадку його застосували до задачі Ізінгового спінового скла. Як ми вже обговорювали, багато комбінаторних
задач оптимізації можна переформулювати як пошук станів із низькою енергією гамільтоніанів Ізінга.
Модель Ізінга — це набір мікроскопічних спінів, розподілених по решітці. Модель може використовуватися для опису спінового скла, в якому
намагніченість невпорядкована — по суті, маленькі магнітні моменти орієнтовані хаотично в решітці.
Чому ж ми вважали, що це спрацює? Ми вже певною мірою розглядали, як боремося з двома типовими проблемами
варіаційних алгоритмів, коли розглядали визначення статті. Але підсумовуючи: алгоритм, який вони
пропонують, прискорює еволюцію для зменшення глибини circuit, одночасно пригнічуючи неадіабатичні переходи.
Крім того, він не покладається на жодну класичну процедуру оптимізації, що може бути проблемою, призводячи до Barren
plateaus та застрягання в локальних мінімумах. Нарешті, автори також подбали про вирівнювання взаємодій у задачному
гамільтоніані з апаратною зв'язністю реального QPU, що завжди дуже важливо. Нарешті, як це працює? Отже,
як я вже казав, тут не використовуються класичні оптимізатори, як це часто буває в ітераційних квантових алгоритмах.
Натомість, подаючи рішення кожної ітерації як вхідні дані для наступної, алгоритм bias field digitized
Quantum optimization поступово уточнює основний стан, наближаючи його дедалі ближче до
кінцевого еволюційованого стану. У поєднанні з counter adiabatic протоколами ми можемо робити це навіть із короткими quantum
circuits, що мають плавно працювати на шумному апаратному забезпеченні. Тож коли експеримент було проведено, автори вирішили запустити
алгоритм на 127-qubit IBM quantum комп'ютері Brisbane. Тут автор показав
ітеризацію алгоритму оптимізації для найближчосусідського випадково згенерованого екземпляра спінового скла
більш ніж 100 qubits. Вони порівнюють ідеальні результати симуляції для DCQ та BF-DCQ,
а також експериментальний результат, і показують також результат класичного солвера під назвою Gurobi як орієнтир. Тепер
лише за 10 ітерацій BF-DCQ забезпечує разюче покращення порівняно з
DCQ. Хоча експериментальний результат дещо відрізняється від ідеального через шум, продуктивність все одно
краща за ідеальний DCQ. Це показує, що у сфері квантової оптимізації досі досягається чудовий прогрес,
і хороші результати вперше отримуються на більш ніж 100 qubits.
Остання, але не менш цікава — дуже цікава стаття, що досліджує передбачення структури мРНК від наших друзів із
Moderna Pharmaceuticals. Вона називається "mRNA secondary structure prediction using utility scale quantum
computers". Для початку, якщо ти, як і я, не брав курс біології кілька років тому — можеш освіжити в пам'яті, що таке
мРНК. Матрична РНК — це тип РНК, що бере участь у синтезі білків.
По суті, вона зчитує інструкції, надані ДНК. Вторинна структура мРНК — це більш-менш те, як ланцюг згорнутий.
Задача передбачення вторинної структури РНК — це задача знаходження найстабільнішого згортання послідовності
основ нуклеотидів, що складають ДНК і РНК: тобто C, G, U та A. Це
зображення показує деякі поширені структури згортання, що зустрічаються в мРНК; кожен колір тут виділяє
іншу вторинну структуру. Але точні характеристики того, що робить одну з цих структур більш переважною за
іншу, не надто добре зрозуміло. Все, що ми можемо зробити, — це з'ясувати, яка з них має найнижчу вільну енергію порівняно з
незгорнутим станом — і саме тут вступають квантові комп'ютери. Тож чому вторинні структури мРНК
важливі? Їхнє точне передбачення насправді є критично важливим не лише для розуміння ДНК та наших генів, але й для
розробки РНК-терапій, як-от вакцина від COVID-19. Є підстави вважати, що підхід у
цій статті спрацює, оскільки давно відомо, що ця задача є серйозною задачею оптимізації для класичних
комп'ютерів через величезну кількість можливих конфігурацій. А для деяких конфігурацій вона, як відомо, є
NP-повною задачею. Однак на квантовому комп'ютері ми можемо сформулювати задачу передбачення вторинної структури як
бінарну задачу оптимізації — те, з чим ми вміємо працювати. Крім того, вже є докази в літературі
точного передбачення РНК на малих квантових пристроях і квантових симуляторах. Тому очевидне питання:
чи спрацює це на більшому апаратному забезпеченні? Експеримент проводиться з використанням так званого conditional value
at risk variational Quantum eigensolver — це модифікація традиційного алгоритму VQE, яка
має досягати кращої збіжності. Цей графік показує розподіл ймовірностей вимірювань
бітових рядків вибірки з відповідними енергіями для 42-
нуклеотидного 80-qubit екземпляра. Тут бітові рядки символізують пари
нуклеотидів. Ілюструється, що бітовий рядок із найнижчою енергією має значення енергії -140, що збігається з
бітовим рядком найнижчої енергії, знайденим порівняльним класичним солвером. Чудово — і це оптимальна згорнута
структура того ланцюга нуклеотидів на основі бітового рядка з найнижчою енергією, яку знайшло апаратне забезпечення.
З цим ми досягли завершення цього епізоду. Моєю метою тут не було перевантажувати тебе
деталями різних наукових статей. Як я вже казав, я просто хотів дати тобі достатньо контексту, щоб зрозуміти,
як виглядає передова робота в цій галузі прямо зараз. Сподіваюся, це запустить деякі шестерні в
головах кожного, і що, бачачи, як інші підходять до задач, ти зможеш проводити зв'язки та мати
впевненість спробувати нові квантові експерименти, яких раніше, можливо, не наважувався. І, можливо, деякі з них не
дадуть результату — і це нормально. Ось чому це дослідження. Пам'ятай, що типи задач, якими ми
цікавимося, можна згрупувати за методологією або за предметом, і ми виклали ті, що вважаємо
найперспективнішими в короткостроковій перспективі. Пам'ятай: Quantum Computing підходить не для всього — і насправді це лише
свідчення того, наскільки добре ми навчилися класичних обчислень. Лише тому, що, на твою думку, можна застосувати Quantum Computing
до задачі, не означає, що це дасть цікаві результати. На жаль, треба враховувати масштабування — глибина circuit
є обопільним мечем: нам потрібно, щоб вона була досить великою для виконання цікавої роботи, яку не можуть виконати класичні
комп'ютери, але зараз через шум апаратного забезпечення ми не можемо доводити її до величезних розмірів, бо точність
погіршиться. Усе зводиться до знаходження тієї золотої середини та усвідомлення, що вона є рухомою ціллю. Тож присвяти трохи часу між
зараз і наступним епізодом, щоб справді подумати про задачі, з якими ти стикався, і про те, як міг би підійти до них з тим, що ми
вивчили до цього моменту. Будь творчим і не обмежуй себе. І якщо маєш ідеї — навіть якщо думаєш, що вони
трохи божевільні — дай знати в коментарях нижче. Дякую за перегляд, і побачимося наступного разу.